okay so there it is I stopped it
that's it going in an amalgam is a
mixture of a metal with mercury and what
happens is that because Mercury's are
liquid the metals can dissolve or a
number of metals can dissolve okay so
what we're going to do today is we're
going to take sodium so this is this is
our sodium it's okay so as you can see
it's stored under liquid paraffin and
this is our mercury here so we're gonna
dissolve sodium at the mercury you know
one of the quite famous ones is sodium
amalgam you've seen that sodium reacts
very violently with water and so if you
want to do reactions where the sodium
doesn't react so violently you can
dilute it by dissolving it into mercury
so what we're gonna do is we're going to
take some of this sodium we'll put it in
some hexane which I don't get the hexane
now we've got to cut it up under
something in it like hexane people use a
lot of things like hexane or petroleum
ether because obviously sodium reacts
with with the oxygen in the air and
forms an oxide layer quite quickly so we
don't really want too much of that going
on and we want to protect it from the
air as much as possible to sort of grasp
quite violently with it you can make
quite nice amalgam from the silver and
Mercury and that's much more like a sort
of paste if you put lots of silver in
and it tends to harden quite quickly so
this is used by dentists in many
countries including the UK to fill
people's teeth and so they have a thin
rod like a syringe and squirts the
amalgam will press it into your teeth
and it then goes quite solid and the
mercury doesn't really leach out at all
or comes out and dissolves that very
very slowly so it doesn't really harm
people what we're gonna do is cut up in
small bits and then drop it in the top
of here and dissolve it up in our
mercury I'll do first actually is get on
a pair of gloves
because the last thing I want is sodium
all over my wet hands though there are
one or two people I had the student
Kumar who once thought that his teeth
might be poisoning him and he had all
his amalgam fillings removed and then he
owned plastic ones put in instead and
then he felt much better
my mouths full of amalgam fillings and I
think it's just probably his teeth
looked nicer and he felt more confident
most people I know have amalgam fillings
of my age so we've got as a little pyrex
dish here
so this is this is hexane so it's a
hydrocarbon okay so it's not going to
react with the sodium so we can
guarantee that we're not going to get
too much water in contact with our
sodium when we cut it up so Sony was
pretty softer we can cut it up with stop
getting stuck to everything in this
place so we can cut it up with a scalpel
which we've got here just get a pair of
tweezers let's get
chunk like that get it under that hexane
as quickly as possible okay so what
we're gonna do is like you would cut up
your Sunday roast there's a little bit
stickier than and roast beef what we do
is we just cut it into little chunks as
I expose it it's all nice and shiny but
it'll probably tarnish a little bit in a
minute so the thing is when we dissolve
the sodium up in this it's going to get
quite hot so we don't to add too much at
any point because I think we could come
undone so if I cut abut just broken my
scalpel that is not good
mercury will also I believe amalgamate
with gold and so if chemists are wearing
a wedding ring you can see I don't wear
a wedding ring for precisely this reason
if they get mercury on their wedding
rings the mercury amalgamates with the
suit of gold wedding ring and you get a
silver patch on it but fortunately it
can quite easily be polished off again
what does your wife think if you're not
wearing a wedding ring for that reason
well she thinks I'm a chemist this is a
magnetic stirrer bar and so when we put
on this it's got a magnet inside it and
it spins and spins and spins and so this
will stir it and as you see you'll
disappear now he'll get dragged back
down there it goes by the magnet so if I
turn this on for a little bit so you can
see our stereo bar is now stirring it so
it's gonna go in now and it should face
with any luck if I can get it in so it
was not worried will it dissolve okay so
there it is I stopped it
that's it going in will keep going for a
little while so what I'm doing is I'm
taking some of the sodium out of the
hexane I give it a little bit of white
to get rid of excess hexane and then
it's going in so we're sitting on
so there's argon gas here and it slowly
dissolves in the mercury and you see it
fizz when it goes in its massive
the thing is is that the more you get
going in there kind of more concentrated
it becomes so the slower it goes in and
there it goes so now it's all those
three blocks of sodium that I put in
there all dissolved in the mercury now
so they made the amalgam so it's getting
warm
to warmish as why is that warm because a
white winter name resolves in when Matt
was dissolving mercury and especially
about the alkali metals like sodium and
potassium it's an exothermic reaction so
it gives off an energy in the form of
heat this is getting nice and warm now
the point is that the sodium is now more
dilute so it reacts more slowly but
because it's a liquid you get clean
surface all the time so that you don't
get solid building up on the surface and
stopping the reaction Sicilia mercury
amalgam there's a little bit of crud on
it unfortunately that's always the way
but now this is so it's a little bit
warm and we've got sodium salt in
mercury so probably about a gram of
sodium dissolved in that mercury there
very good city mercury amalgam is a very
good reducing agent
I think the Spanish do use them in 16th
century forum so though the people that
kind of went out and conquered various
places for purifying and the silver that
they they they big conquered is that
your history oh thank you that is that's
that's history biochemist which probably
isn't very good but I think it's used
less and less amalgams because obviously
the environmental impacts of mercury
people people shy away from using
mercury